Arrays are perhaps the most
common implementations of lists.
In many programming languages,
the ability to create an array
is built in as a core feature.
You may have seen or
heard of them before but
it's important to have a more formal
definition of what an array is so
we can compare them to other
data structures a bit later.
As I mentioned before an array is
a list with a few added rules so
we all ready know that it has
some things in some order.
In some languages you can only have
objects with the same types in
the same array.
And in some languages your array
can contain different types so
we can't use that as
a rule to define arrays.
It would also be nice
to say that arrays have
a set size that you determine
right when you create them.
Again, this is only true in
some programming languages so
we need to avoid adding
that to our definition.
Defining the thing that different
languages call arrays is actually
pretty hard.
There is one big feature that
differentiates arrays from lists.
Each array has a location
called an index.
An index is just the number associated
with that place in the array.
It would make sense to number
these boxes from one to five.
But of course it can't be that simple.
Normally, an index starts at zero so
instead of referring to these boxes as
one to five, we usually say it's 0 to 4.
Having indices can make
using arrays a great or
sometimes terrible choice for
the code you're working on.
If you need to access a certain
location in the middle frequently,
using an array can be a great choice.
You just need to keep track
of how long the array is.
Calculate the middle element and check
the object in the box with that index.
Insertion and deletion can be
really messy with arrays though.
Inserting in the end is often easy but
it can be hard if the array has a set
size and you've already filled it up.
Insertion is difficult if you want
to put an element in the middle
of the array.
If you want to do a normal insert
you'll need to move everything
after the inserted element back into
different boxes with a different index.
The operation as a whole is pretty
inefficient since you need to move
every element behind the one you're
inserting back in the array.
In the worst case this operation
takes linear time or a big O of n.
Deletion causes a similar problem.
If you delete an element
you have an empty box.
You can't just look at the index and say
that this is the fourth element anymore
since there's an empty box before it.
Again all of this can change based on
the way a particular language implements
an array but it's important to consider
when talking about arrays abstractly.